before we say goodbye we'd love to play
a quick round up truth or dare
we have stacy louise jacques hi stacy hi
how are you i'm great how are you guys
good i love your beautiful bright
colored top all right so we're down what
is it going to be a drew or dare i have
a truth okay have you ever snuck out of
a date before it was over
i wish i knew that i could oh yeah right
i am that person also who like goes to a
long-winded meal
yeah at 47 i'm finally learning don't do
a meal on a date is this something
everybody knows oh yeah so no i i would
like hot tips in fact right into the
drewberrymartian.com
and let us know a good way to get out of
a bad date yeah
i have never ever snuck out of a date no
no no i mean i wanted to leave i just
was grateful to be there because it was
dinner you understand what i'm saying
like
it was good
what about you stacy have you ever snuck
out of a date
well i have never actually done it but
there was a time that i wish i did
yeah yeah we've all been there you know
what you got to do the move is give like
your best friend you say hey call me 15
years who knows that everybody knows
that the phone call is a ruse i know you
should see me fake it i can't all right
do it right now oh drew i'm just oh no
i'm sorry my um
cat is hungry
well thank you stacy
[Music]